the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license
your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
ok
hope you had the hall a good weekend it
was very lovely we had a lot of fun you
know during the weekend so recall what
we're talking the last lecture we
discussed the Maxwell equations electric
field this is a say very magnetic field
that generate electric field current
generate magnetic field and what Maxwell
added is the displacement field that see
the time derivative also general
magnetic field right so this set of four
equations form the Maxwell equation and
one comment that I thought I forgot to
make is this is actually called
macroscopic Maxwell equation and you can
write atomic macro scale as a maxim
Maxwell equation that does not involve
the displacement because displacement
recall is the the polarization due to
external field plus external field
together right it's the the response of
the atoms to the external field and
similarly magnetic induction also
include magnetic moment and say magnetic
field so the atomic Maxwell equation
actually you can go to write without
those say D and B but you have to sum up
over all atoms and you do not use the
concept of dielectric constant and this
is in fact
we're currently trying to work huh to
bridge to build a bridge between the
heat conduction and electromagnetic wave
because we're doing an experiment when
two surface is really really close like
one nanometer close originally your use
we're using the maximum macroscopic
Maxwell equation but in this regime
we're no longer we're questioning
whether that's about it or not so but
coming back say from this set of
macroscopic Maxwell equations we can
find a plane wave solution for the wave
propagating in a homogeneous media a
homogeneous media means I have the
permeability and permittivity
permittivity and permeability
independent our for space so it's a
function of frequency but it's in deep
enough free space and in this case the
wave vector when we substitute back into
the equation we find the wave vector is
related to frequency that's a dispersion
relation through the permittivity and
permeability which when we normalize to
vacuum values we have the relative
dielectric constant and as a relative
magnetic permeability and so this is the
square so if I take the magnitude of the
wave vector right it's a vector
magnitude wave vector I can write this
equation in terms of Omega and Omega
equals CK that's what are your familiar
ways for free space right I'll say the
wavelength times frequency equals speed
of night that's what it gives and this n
is the refractive index the optic
constant of the material and different
material have different object constant
but it's not a constant okay and is a
very frequency dependent so
it's a misnomer so if you take the
derivative of 4n normally we take only
the positive root so most of the kids
don't worry about it it's a positive
root refractive index equals square root
directory constant and relative magnetic
permittivity permeability and let's say
in after your frequency range this is a
1 usually so it's really just the square
root of dielectric constant and because
this one could be met in including
imaginary part so when you take a root
generally your up your constant have a
real part and an imaginary part and the
imaginary part is associated
particularly if some are the imaginary
part associated with the loss and the
correspondingly this Kappa which we call
extinction coefficient is also
associated with the loss the damping of
the wave when it propagates through the
medium and we said that if you check
basically these are all characteristics
you can derive from the equation right
this primary solution and if you plug in
plan one solution you find that this is
a ye you can also use that find the H
then e is perpendicular to H so that's
the two field are perpendicular to each
other and it's perpendicular to the
direction of propagation and that's why
the electromagnetic wave is a transfer
with transfers way it's perpendicular to
the ration propagation and also normally
it's right-handed wave because if the
cross H gives you the K direction and
that's when you take the square root as
a positive and negative square root is
just a recent invention the theory was
there but to say was really it's a
matter mature field is based on
designing artificial structures so that
when both epsilon and the mule are
negative you should take elective
we comment at the end of last lecture so
this were where we were it's basically
giving you the vector equations and if
you recall before this we're looking at
the electron it's not it's a scalar wave
is a we're looking at the electron
reflection at a potential step right so
we give a reflectance and transmittance
at the interface and the world we're
going is doing the same same i have
electromagnetic wave comes towards the
interface what's the corresponding
reflectance what's corresponding
transmitters and similarly after that we
go to acoustical wave right and acoustic
wave is the more complicated a young way
because they had three polarization
longitudinal which is the same as the K
vector vibration direction and two
transverse so that is even more
complicated and but we're going to at
least a give you some idea of this or
different waves actually behave from way
perspective actually very similarly in
terms of the behavior so let's continue
and what we want first is a further
looking at the wave propagation in
homogeneous medium
and if you use the Maxwell equation this
is a water you can prove and I'm not
going to write the max because it's very
involving right right back here let me
just point out so when you use Maxwell
equation what you can do you can
multiply H to this equation what do you
see P is amuh right so that's one half
mu H square that's like the magnetic
field energy store energy and if you
multiply this by Yi and what you have
here is the IFS known say he is an
instant on e right so you get a 1/2 if
salome e square that's the electric
field energy stored and when you add
them in together
the left-hand side will give you the
rate of change of energy stored in the
system if you take it any system you
apply it and the right hand it should be
the flux that going across the system
boundaries right so that's the
interpretation if you do math operation
and what you find out is then that flux
of energy going across the system
boundary gives you the energy flux of
electromagnetic wave and this is the
pointing vector pointing vector is e
cross H so e cross H is the energy
propagation the rushing okay and if you
think about my electric field is varying
as a function of Omega T so the
instantaneously my s the energy flux
right pointing vector gives me the
energy flux
I should not say the renergie really
should be power flux and what I have
here is the is a function of 2 Omega
time-wise right because if you look at
the Yi is the AIA Omega and if you have
a 2 sine Omega times the each other
Omega T times each other you get a 2
mega T so the energy the power flux here
is a rapidly changing function with time
because the frequency of a light visible
light at least you know it's a 10 to the
14 Hertz so 2 Omega will give you even
much faster right
so in this case normally we don't care
we can't measure we cannot measure the
instantaneous power here and what we
measure is time average power so if you
go to do your time average time average
and now proof but it's much easier if
you calculate this way it's the
equivalent okay is the e cross H complex
conjugate and if you go to think about
the mass flux from the Schrodinger
equation we rotate as also real part all
for supersonic and the greeting of a
plasma cell complex conjugate so you see
the similarity between those different
flux I'm writing this as the e cross H
complex conjugate okay so all those are
see see this is a time average point
pointing vector and now let's look at if
I have the plan wave propagating inside
the media
right how it would change how the
pointing vector change as a function of
space so let's say I have a plan B and I
I'm carefully taking my coordinate this
is Zeta rushing that's the directional
propagation and this is the Yi the
ration is in the X so X Y so Y then say
I would expect my magnetic field will be
pointing you cross H gives me Z pointing
out okay but you can prove it right you
can use your e let's say my electric
field in the e X Omega T as so it's X
component right you like if you are
pointing to X the rationale me and the
magnitude of the electric field times
exponential master I and if you replace
K relation here what do we have K equals
Omega C 0 n so I can take all the Omega
so Omega t minus and say zero times a
this is a righty in my plane wave for
electric field in the polarized in the X
direction probably ain't in the Z
direction okay so from here you find out
y X I can go back here because I don't
know H right I said that H is a function
is only in the Y direction only and in
fact you can use the Maxwell equation to
prove it so to find the H I use the
first equation right the curve all for
electric field so I can say here what I
have is a unit vector X Y
z and have D D X D D Y and the D is a
right so this is the day for calculated
a curve and I have e^x so X component Oh
me DX 0 0 that's the left-hand side
right of the first equation and the e^x
is a function of Z remember it's the e^x
is just so the vector Direction is not a
function of X is a function of Z if you
look high here on the right hand side I
have P P is meal so deep
Samuel D H DT so I have D H X DT and
this is the X Direction D H Y DT why the
Russian pH is a dt z direction right so
I'm writing out the first equation there
vector ok and now if you look at it I
said this is a function of Z times Z on
me so I don't say it's only a function
of Z and time so if I take a derivative
of this I of course to the X component
so X I take out of this I have all 0
right so that means X is zero right
actually X is zero and then I look at ax
if I look at the Z component here here
so DZ DT D 0 D X that's 0 DX dy
but the Yi X is a function of Z only
right so that's also 0
so I have a chose a 0 so this is
validate whether we're talking it's a
transverse wave and H is a perpendicular
to e I only have the second term the Y
term the hy DT because the Y if I see it
look at this write a vector so I take
this two out so I have this 0 T 0 DX and
then I have a DX DZ this Y is not 0
right so I have really nice meal d hy
the T equals - this is the second term
on the first roast at my size - and then
I have this is a positive this is
another negative is minus d DX DZ right
so I now my e^x I have given my e^x DX
DZ I take out the derivative I integrate
that with respect to time I get my hy
right so let me write down H Y in this
case what do you get with other going
through the intermediate steps my H Y
component is e 0 times n mule C 0 and
exponential mass I Omega T mass and C 0
times Z so again it's a wave propagating
in the Z direction right and there's
only wider of the ration components and
not 0 so it's the perpendicular to the
electric field and in fact if you look
how easy arrow times this essentially is
my
i yi X right easier all times does the
exponential factor this is my X naught
at the vector
it's just they form in the X direction
so in fact let me use this right at the
N mu 0 C 0 times the ax and pass a this
is the magnitude of e X is not a vector
ax because of the component is it
divided the Russian okay so that's H Y
right I had when I do my pointing vector
I will need all three components so
that's why I'm writing out and in fact
water if you have a positive sign if
rather than rather than negative that's
a for propagating if you have a backward
propagating and your corresponding sign
here in the front that will also change
and you have in that case you'll have h
y equals negative and mu c 0 mu 0 c 0
and e XY and this is the full negative
propagating wave a sign change and
that's understandable because what i
have here right this is a propagation
direction i say it's a right hand wave
so you cross H is pointing out but now
if the wave goes the other direction as
you are pointing the opposite direction
to form my right highway okay and I
commented when both E and I say mule and
if some on our leg here
right you have to do your left hand and
if you look at this here hy from you is
leg here right
that changes the rushing are real the
rushing of
the magnetic field and similarly if we
usually like here they change real
direction so the negative root is the
actually of this refractive index here
is actually the requirement from the
Maxwell equation itself there's no it's
just a math requirement right so it was
the first pointing out by this Russian
scientist or NACO if both sieves wrong a
mule and they get here you should take
the elective route but the nature of
materials all have say if the mule
pretty close to vacuum so if the MU R is
one soul or Malay people see that's just
academic exercise on tearing in Atlantis
people start to actually make artificial
structure have a magnetic residence so
the magnetic response resists the
external magnetic field and that could
generate a negative mu and in this case
when you can design material with the
Bose if some time you negative together
and become negative okay so I I'm not
done yet
I have my e^x I have my hy and I can go
calculate pointing vector right so let's
calculate the pointing vector and so
this is the complexity with the vector
wave so you have to do always vector
operation right if you look at that
you're pointing vector okay
and at the end that you'll find out this
is the only z component there's no X Y
component because your e^x is the X
direction and a cheese invite the
Russian and the cross product is only in
the Z direction right so let me escape
that the vector form and I just say this
is a time every vector in the Z
direction with one half real part of e
now e^x
h.y complex conjugate and this is
whether you get if you write all these
three components and you only have this
iteration component so now I can plug in
e ex and hy right and they you have to
be careful this n refractive index or up
your constant as opposed to real and you
imagine pot so when I take a complex
conjugate this one I take complex this
one i take complex this ayah taking
inverse and this n I have to take
complex conjugate right so you have to
do all that and you see I Omega t minus
I Omega T because the plus I Omega T so
I o matic hand so right ye is negative I
Omega T right because that slasher
because I actually I was doing time
average as time should not be there so
this is always kind so time and so what
I have then is the one half real part of
e zero that's the electrical field and
exfol ensure negative negative is
positive N and C 0 times Z that's the
first e^x hy is a easier role complex
conjugate and complex conjugate divided
by mu 0 C 0 and I take a mule is pretty
much it as a in vacuum and then I have
an exponential and this becomes a plus I
and this is a negative so I have
exponential negative and complex
conjugate c0z that's my pointing vector
right so what do you have you like to
get field complex conjugate that's just
a magnitude right this is a real now
here I have to be careful is real part
only imagine part drops out and this to
exponent sure is n mass and complex
conjugate right
that gives me to I Kappa right to I
Kappa oh I forgot there's another I
Omega I Omega should multiply in so I
actually have I Omega I have I Omega
right so n and complex on yet will give
me a to I Kappa turns to this another I
actually is real so here n is real here
is the major part in the exponent so
what I have then is the one-half e 0
square and mu 0 C 0 and the real part
and and Expo lecture minus 4 pi Kappa
over lambda and this lambda is lambda in
vacuum I have used say Omega C 0 right
Omega RC 0 equals 2 PI over lambda so I
substitute this yield and that's the how
the pointing vector in a homogeneous
medium of refractive index and Kappa is
changing in the Z direction here is Z
it's exponentially decay function right
that X for a decaying solid alpha is a 4
pi Kappa over lambda this is an
absorption coefficient
okay and the universe of this absorption
coefficient sometimes I call the skin
depth so if the universe that's a depth
so you can say when Z equals that skin
depth inverse right Delta equals 1 or
alpha and the skin when Delta Z equals
Delta we have these they feel that decay
to exponential minus 1 ok so what do we
learn here you can say that when
electron my let me feel the propagating
in lhasa media Kappa is now zero right
they feel decay exponentially and that's
the electromagnetic wave is absorbed by
the medium right and in fact this is
very important when you make your solar
cells right this determines how deep the
photon penetrating into the material and
silicon is a indirect gap semiconductor
so the Alpha is small near the band gap
so it's not a good absorber and because
of that you have to use a pretty thick
material to absorb the photons and so
that is a big problem with the
photovoltaics
siga photovoltaic the cut material cost
okay so any questions so this is a
propagating in the same medium and the
exponential law so sometimes we can
write so this is the pointing vector
right and if they see the power flux and
sometimes we write the intensity in
intensity is the energy per unit
the angle right intensity propagating in
medium is exponential alpha times the X
will exit the rational propagation this
is another way to write the same form
and this is also called a beer snore
it's a consequence L for the Maxwell
equation but it's a it's called the beer
slope okay so if you have a light comes
in onto a surface and what do we wrote
down here is the propagating inside the
medium okay so we didn't we have not
talked about how much is reflected and
whether we talked today is once you know
this field in this direction at this
point the the flux and it will decay
exponentially inside right so a material
could be very flattened but the very
absorbing what does that mean it's
conflicting right so what does that mean
is that the reflectance is very large
right the reflections are is very large
amateur could be 99% reflecting but once
the Megrahi back to my Lackey we getting
into the material the penetration test
is very short it's absorbed those that
getting into the surface is absorb the
inverse short distance in fact all
metals behaved that way right matter
very flaky oh the feel that they may be
1 or 5% of this wave gets into the metal
absorb the Tipperary in 10 nanometers 10
20 nanometers okay so if you have
interactive gap of a semiconductor I see
huh
this penetration depth can be millimeter
right if you do millimeter you want to
capture that material so you may get
solar cell millimeter means a lot more
materials or it was expensive
okay so this is a day what's the inside
propagation and now let's turn our
attention to what happens at the
interface right that are what's the
reflectance what's the transmittance
reflection at the Y interface and this
is a very similar to the scalar wave
from the shorting question we talked the
last lecture and what we need is the
field on both sides of the interface and
use the continuity relation if you think
about how we did with the material wave
right the wave function here you have
the wave function on the Left equals
right at the interface and derivative
equal to each other so that's how we
derived the reflectance transmittance
for Mature waves and we do the same same
for electromagnetic waves so what I have
here is a flat interface one and the
tool right and let me make my life
slightly easier by saying here is m1
okay I can write a capital N 1 right if
I just write a small and white means the
low loss if I write the capital 1 1
minister has lost okay and here I can
write n 2 and I'll extend to the case
when they're lost discuss it write the
mass is identical but there are some
subtle differences and I have the Z
Direction this is my Z direction with
propagation and this is my X direction
and I have a wave comes in towards the
interface this is my K the Russian
that's the incident wave the Russian
right and I have the norm of the surface
n right so ki here is a angle of
incidence theta I and the ki is the wave
propagation of the incident wave right
two vectors two lines formal plan right
so this plan Aiko is a plan of incidence
this is how I define my reference plan
right so I have my plan of incidence and
this is a form of that by N and K I this
is these are the two vectors for my plan
of the incident okay now I have to say
they feel is a vector field is
perpendicular to K I right but I have to
define which is the ration because it
could be any of this the ration
perpendicular to K I okay but I can any
of this vector I can decompose in the
two the sum of two vectors right so I
can always define if one case is my if I
think this is my electric field is the
in the plan the other case is a
perpendicular to the plan right and once
you know the solution is a linear
combination of the two so any other
direction you decompose the in plan and
cross plane perpendicular direction and
so but then you have the choice of or
now depends on if this is my electric
field my magnetic field now if you use
Andrew what's the duration magnetic
field
coming up right so ye you see then and
that's a vector and the magnetic field
is a pointing out okay so there are
three limbs for this depends on which
one you we need to remember it turns
turns out for over this many years I
always get confused okay
my simplest I will just say okay I like
to remember this as a TM way TM means
transverse magnetic okay so this case
what I draw is a TM wave that's the
magnetic field is perpendicular
perpendicular to the plane of incidence
okay so three lines the other two limbs
is relative to the electric field then
is the parallel to the plan of incidence
so the so here is the Uni record at EMF
or you quite the parallel P wave or you
use a symbol of Harlow there's three
different notations right the not the
what I have here is for the T for the
electric field and here is when I say
transverse is whatever
what's a follow right transverse is the
TM that means magnetic field is
perpendicular te means the electrical
field is perpendicular so what I'm going
to derive is the situation where the
magnetic field is a prepping there to
the plan of an incident okay and now I
need to write when the wave comes in
I could have reflection I have
transmission right so here reflection
the we vector and transmission the wave
vector and in each medium I have a plan
wave form I know the plan wave form this
is my plan wave form I do not know the
amplitude
right and my wave vector
I need to relate to what the rash in the
way is going for the reflected and
transmitted right so here is my CTR if I
use a moment in Anglo see that T to
denote it right so I can write because
if I want to write this kid that are
right R is any point in the plan XYZ and
K I have to write it now in terms of the
location I have this K I have to say
kxkykz
okay and I write my K you need a vector
now the magnitude right the this is the
total the total of course is related to
Omega C and but what's the unit vector
is related to the rationale only right
so the unit vector I can write it as
this is the vector direction so whether
what's my under my C Z is a K times to
the cosine theta i right actually the
science it huh so I have really my
science it ha I 0 cosine say hi and this
is my incident wave vector and my
universe of reflection is here plus R so
X Direction is still sine theta R 0 but
the Z direction is negative now this is
my propagation direction right my Z
direction is negative so negative cosine
theta R and mighty direction oh this
unit vector is sine see that T 0 cosine
see that heat and then we encourage you
to everybody
really get comfortable it took me many
many years get comfortable but say at
least that you should do your exercise
and I say I'm giving you TM where you
can go back and do a te wave and go
through the derivation of what the
reflectors what's a transmittance one
wave go through a interface and I made a
comment in the last lecture when people
do electrical or say this material wave
Mac sorting or equation we did a lot
more incidence right and here you can
see I'm doing general any angle of
incidence so you should go back and redo
that problem any angle of incidence
you'd be able to do it okay so now what
I do next is to write a component
because I need a boundary conditions
right recall for the material wave
Schrodinger equation is the wave
functions continuous derivative wave
function is continuous and what's Mike
responding boundary condition for
Maxwell equation and it turns out that
any interface and this is a straight
very general how you derive an interface
condition when you do heat transfer you
do the same you apply so when you do a
heat transfer you apply your boundary
condition to you apply your equation
energy balance to both sides of the
interface right so if I have it this is
a let's say many of you probably for
more familiar with the heat transfer so
while right try to write down the
boundary condition for this if this is a
liquid this is solid right apply the
energy conservation I see on the solid
side that heat conduction coming towards
this interface of course the convection
going through the other interface I'm
applying the first law the thickness is
zero right there is a heat comes in from
here but in my limit is thickness 0 so
that term drops out when you apply first
law you have four surfaces in my drawing
here right
so I do the same thing when I do Maxwell
equation or you do Schrodinger equation
how I Drive you applies it in the case
of Schrodinger equation and you have
your material waived as in the matter
must be continuous right with that you
can write the equation we give before
and here I have to say apply take that
control volume apply all those four
equations integrate over that control
volume and take a little emmitt that the
sickness approaches zero right and with
that you can write down or your boundary
conditions and the boundary condition is
they and the unit vector of the the norm
and d2 minus d1 equals Rho surface this
is a day
the real charge accumulation on the
surface okay if you have a current
flowing uniformly through the material
everywhere you have a current density
right in that case what's your surface
charge density zero because everywhere
is uniform when you gather your
thickness go to zero that's the total
number of charge in this wall infinite
small thickness is zero so normally this
is zero but if you do your let's say
some of you may work with
electrochemistry right and in this case
you have absorbed the charge on the
surface and in that case your surface
charge is not zero okay so you can say
what is the n dot product I mean so is
the vertical component right the
component perpendicular to interface
because of this interaction there's a
parallel to n direction
so basically the displacement field
is the difference is the surface charge
because the surface each a surface
charge add a Coulomb field on top of it
the addition it gives you the difference
in the surface in the displacement field
and then you have the tangential is then
is a cross product to the interface so
so this is a parallel component is zero
so the electric field that is parallel
to the interface it continues okay and
then you do your magnetic first is the
dot product is zero and the tangential
component is the surface charge okay
surface current again the surface
current is something that you need to be
careful really depends on for example I
give you a kiss if I have a graph in
[ __ ] I try to make a solar cell and
graphene sheet is my electrode right and
when I try to apply the boundary
condition I will say that in that case
because of the graphene sheet that has a
much higher current density than the
rest of the region I will take that as
my surface current density but most of
time if there is some genius material
and you take your infinite thickness
this drops out so what it also means is
a magnetic field congenial component is
usually continuous so so basically
electrical field is continuous because
of D I know this D has to be if some - D
- E - if someone knew one so but
tangential component is continuous
electric field and magnetic field the
the perpendicular components continuous
and the tangential component is the
difference of the electric current
surface current the other way to think
of a surface current is you know that
when a wire flew or through a conductor
current you got a magnetic field
surrounding right so when I have a
surface charge card flowing here I have
a magnetic field going in the tangential
direction that's why you have this
relations but that's all derived from
applying the master equation to the
interface okay so those are the general
conditions and now I'm going to apply
those condition I need to write down I
do need to do a little bit dirtier work
write down all those components
tangential and perpendicular component
and they apply the boundary condition
you to write electric field magnetic
field
so but if you need to develop a habit
right yeah it's all plan wave that's
what I wrote down before and for the TM
wave where the electric field is what I
use it in right so it's you see then I
have three waves why is the use of that
the others reflect with others
transmitted I have to write down all of
them to count right so this is the
incident and it's vector because not a
parallel to X or parallel so any
direction right I have the angle so and
then X will ensure I need to carry my
face factor must I Omega T - you go to
look at ax what do we have here K dot R
right K I already put out so Omega C
there are times N and now I have ki is
sine theta cosine see the i0 right and
the R is X Y Z so the dot product of
these two gives me m1 X sine theta I
plus n1 z cosine see the eye so this is
the where should be careful and see zero
that's incident
okay and it's really a tedious but I say
once you get used to it this is just a
phase factor right and remember this one
actually has a component because the
vector e I write has a component in
acceleration and has component in the Z
direction so this is a you can say is a
e^x and 0e z the incident and you can do
your vector decomposition to write down
this component right so you similarly
write what's a day reflect it and
exponent and then very strong orders the
exponents are going to drop out so I
just want to write it to show you how we
got this how white it drops out - and 1
because Z cosine theta R over c 0 recall
right because this is K R it has a
negative so I have positive becomes
negative
see how I becomes theta R and the every
is still medium one and transmit it let
me say parallel parallel and exponential
minus I Omega t minus and 2 X sine see
that T plus and whoo I can just look
like that times a course I see that here
I'm just changing my symbol and and the
changing media from media one to medium
- right
so it looks very long it's just the face
factor I'm writing out the details and
this is the amplitude and vector of the
transmitted reflected with which we want
to find out and in fact we also want to
find out what other it direction see
that reflected the ration and
transmitted the rushing we will not
assuming anything a priori right so we
have the electric field we also one
write that the magnetic field and if you
check a load for any plan wave if I can
write that's how the in the homogeneous
media we see we derived right given
electric field I can derive with
magnetic field you go to the first
equation you write the other magnetic
field component and then you know in
this case magnetic field is TM wave it's
only in the Y direction right so let me
give you right this is a Yi right and H
is in the Y direction remember is hy
only because that's the part of the mass
you substitute in and also part of the
physics and we say well considering TM
with so this is only y direction and you
can say that in the it's related to
electric field after use the first
equation so N 1 mu 0 C 0 and is a power
law of the electric field so it's
related to magnitude of the electric
field incident this is a the incident
magnetic field right and backwards
reflected is going backward so there is
a negative sign the other way to think
about negative sign is if this is the
electric
field and this is the same in the same
direction you can see here across the
edge the edge must be going into the
board so I have a little sign that's a
lecherous if you is it's when you
substitute into equation you'll get this
so mu 0 C 0 and exponent sure T let me
write this phase factor is the same
phase factor is the same as reflected
and unto mule 0 say there oh and
parallel oh this is our reflected this
is a transmitter exponential phase
factor of transmitter so here with the
loading this one is a 5 incident and
this is the Phi reflected and what's the
inside here is my fight transmitter okay
so what really is tedious is carrying
out this face factor which will drop out
the very quickly right now I'm going to
apply the continuity the electric field
Tan gingers tangential component because
I don't have any surface charge
Tanzania's component electric field a
magnetic field that all continues okay
and you see you could apply the
perpendicular field it's continuous and
either way you'll get the same result
okay
so let me apply this relation what I
have here is the
and gingers component so electric field
and my electric field is in the
tangential component is the e X
continuous in the X direction right if
you look at that my electric field in
the X direction for an incident for
reflected I have to project that into
all X direction and that's so they feel
you need to sum up for each side it's a
total field it's not just a one I didn't
say incident will reflect it's a total
field on each side right same when we do
the wave function is the total wave
function due to incident and reflection
so this field summation it's very
different then when you do this
typically if you take in radiation it's
doing intensity add up now I'm doing the
field add up and that equals to the
other side so if I do this what I have
here is e IX so instead an X component
and exponent sure I need to carry this
phase factor Z is zero I was clever
choosing my coordinate Z is zero at the
interface so all these drop out right
and Omega T I Omega T you look at the
every term has a negative ion got heat
that will drop off right so I'm not
going to carry my xylem got he I'm not
writing down Z Z equals zero
and I'm only X so I'm going to write
this X component term is I Omega N 1 X
and sine theta over C 0 that's what the
incident come
: in the x-direction and the reflected
component in the X Direction exfol
insurer I Omega 1 1 X sine theta R
equals C over C 0 equals transmitted in
the X Direction exponential I Omega and
2 X sine theta I oversee 0 so this is
the continuity in the electric field in
the X direction I can write the magnetic
field similarly but I want to do one
argument so that I can drop out all
those exponent you can look at this this
equation has to be valid for X point
every point X right in the plan right
for that to happen
your only way is the order the exponent
or equal to each other otherwise you
have zero solution right because I only
have one transmitter one reflected so so
X if would for this equation to have a
long trivial solution or exponent short
terms equal to each other and when I
have this Omega of course doesn't change
and so you can see the N 1 sine theta
from here equals n 2 n 1 sine theta R
equals n to side see that he if that
happens it gives me all the exponent I
equal so this is what they learn high
school right optics the incident angle
you course reflector angle
shanell oh right instead that this
solution is see that I equals theta R
and N 1 sine theta equals in two
sentences at T that's a refraction all
right so this gives me theta I equals
theta R and N 1 sine theta I equals n 2
sine theta T ok so this is a snare law
and another way to think about this is
if you look back into our general
solution this exponent is the KX right K
X times X so what I have here
is a KX the times X so KX is the
continues so KX must be say I incident
equals KX reflected equals KX
transmitted and this is often called
that the latter momentum conservation
right the momentum component in the
direction parallel to the interface are
conserved for incident and reflected and
transmitted right so it turns out
depends on who you're talking to people
use a completely different term see a
person for specular smooth surface here
we say very smooth we don't have many an
assumption of the surface roughness in
this case I have an incident in equal
reflection and Shannel or valid and then
say I think that you heard me talking
about the gradients bragger reflection
right if I have periodic structure on
the surface right and turns out this
momentum conservation this momentum is
suitable like crystal momentum is
another exactly you have to always obey
it so this structure when it has a
component in the X direction in this
case if it's a purely a strategy in the
X direction it gives you this structure
the geometrical move as a component of
we vector in this direction that's the
broad condition right so when you have a
like I'm saying save her article
structure you have reflection only in
certain spots right this case is the
crystal provide you lateral momentum so
this momentum conservation rule here
lateral momentum conservation if you
have roughness you assure your light can
go many directions right so if you
play the rough random your reflashing
actually can go in the case of her Arak
it goes certain spots and it's a rough
you go all the Russians right so it's a
here is a roughened surface that
provides you this is your metrical
momentum needed to obey the momentum
conservation rule so depending like I
said depends on who you talk to and then
one I deal with you like to my gradual
way people normally say this is a rough
surface and diffuse reflashing you talk
to electrical engineer there you check
the electrical newtrich err they don't
talk about rough surface they all say
okay is a momentum conserved or long
conserved
right it's talking about Simpson okay
and so now with that I drop out all the
exposure you can say here this equals
this equals this so I have written a lot
of complex expressions now I'm going to
simplify this right let me write and I'm
going to simplify to have e IX plus e I
are equals e TX that's my this gives the
snail or gives me the X component of the
electric field is continuous right the
magnitude now the phase factor already
taken care by this journal right and of
course the e IX is the e I cause I said
hi right and the this is a parallel
component this is work talking about the
TM wave plus e parallel are reflected
cosine theta R equals e transmitted
cosine theta
he so this is a they asked the reading
in in terms of the amplitude of the
incident reflected transmitted field now
I have my legs relation this is a
magnetic field is continues right
magnetic field is the Y direction and
doesn't have it because there's only y
direction you see this is all white
component right so on the first media I
have the sum of this tool the phase
factor is same general law equals to the
second medium so what I have here is an
one and in kind in fact the music cancel
right music is the same so n1e parallel
I malice here the reflected is a young
one a parallel are equals and two on the
other side II parallel T so those sided
who equations I went through two I'm
looking for I'm looking for how much is
reflected versus the incident
how much is transmitted field versus
incident and I have enough equation to
do that right so now you go to solve for
this ratio and I have my reflection
coefficient is a II parallel R II Pirlo
I equals m1 cosine theta T mass n 2
cosine theta I and and one cosine see
the t plus and two cosine theta I so
this is the
reflection coefficient and transmission
coefficient is a tool on one cosine
theta I and and one cosine theta
I know citta see that he + + 2 cosine
sit hi same denominator so those are the
reflection and transmission coefficient
is not a reflectance transmittance yet
right okay right so you cross this this
is an one cosine see that he and two
cosine she died this switch right yeah
it's different expression you feel look
at the T so if you look at that it's if
the te polarization you'll get slight
different expression but it's a similar
so I will not remember this every time I
have to check okay but what we have now
is the magnitude of reflected and
transmitted fields and based on this I
can go further calculate the pointing
vector right I will Calculon my pointing
vector because I want to find the energy
so you're pointing vector and you can
say for this case you have a component
in the X direction you have component in
the Z direction and whether you really
care where you go through an interface
at least if you look at transporter in
the interface Direction is what's a
component in the Z direction right
that's the energy flux growing across
the interface
right so if you check your pointing
vector and we will define reflectance
our equals parallel in the Z Direction
reflected incident in the Z direction
and a you see it's just a reflection
coefficient squirt okay and that's
because the courtroom if you go to check
your load pointing vector as in this in
the homogeneous media you will say there
is something like a complex refractive
index
but if because it's in the same media
that cancels okay so that's they just a
few page your go we talked about it at
the beginning right and transmittance in
fact maybe I should have used
transmissivity for a flat surface as I
said if you do rigorous it's an
intrinsic mature property right but if
you have rough we do reflectance
transmittance if its intrinsic is
reflectivity transmissivity and here is
the idea and so that's if you have ideal
surface you always have this so
transmittance how this is a it doesn't
matter whether it's a parallel or
perpendicular wave and but here what I
have is for transmittance I have to be
careful because the pointing vector is
going from one side to the other so I
have n to cosine see that he and real
powerful own one so this is a one they
see how I this is the one both sides
have say complex refractive index okay
that's a this here is where it's a
little bit more complex okay so here is
called a friend nail coefficient French
so framel coefficients for reflection
transmission at the interface here is
the for parallel polarized so that's the
electric field is in deprived incidence
and important to me for the parallel
here and if it's a electric field in the
probe near the power of incidence you go
through the same derivation and they're
different set of frontier coefficients
and with and here gives you the
reflectance and transmittance base out
those coefficients okay so ah let me
make a few more comments right here we
we say this is a the that we discuss the
name here is this is a TM the other name
is so here is TM where you for the
electric field is a perpendicular to the
plane of incidence called the T wave and
this is the S and perpendicular sign so
it depends on which book a rate you use
its own notation and in fact say there
is a Ewan more confusing if you read a
different book and sometimes the people
write n equals and my side couple okay I
wrote an M plus I Kappa right and that
depends on whether in this way for a
factor time way of expression
where I put the negative sign in the
front if you don't use this negative
sign you should have an minus I Kappa so
I'd like to put the negative sign so
that the N plus I Kappa different book
is a different notation that there is no
consistency I can't solve that problem
okay
the other is let's look at those
expression and in fact that you read a
Penry's paper if you have that you're
doing your homework right he is exactly
what we have here
Chanel oh for our surface wave for the
when the epsilon mu is negative and
sometimes this goes to infinite this R
itself goes to infinite what I mean
there are goes infinite it just means
that there's no wave can come in and
couple to the surface so in that case
what it has is a surface wave and the
wave it decays exponentially from both
sides of the surface right so what they
had is waved that it decays
exponentially from the surface both
sides and this is where he was
discussing different solutions of the
Maxwell equation so hopefully you see
that it's not too far from what we
discussed you just need to recognize
this and also when theta I is 0 that's a
little more incident right when theta is
0 cosine theta T orders are 0 so what I
have here is R equals M 1 minus n 2 and
1 plus n 2 right so if you go to check
for the
mature wayward arrived at the last
lecture it's K 1 minus K 2 K 1 plus K 2
it's the same expression and in fact
that you can write into K we pendra use
ok completely Hendrix paper you go to
read he used ok he didn't use and and he
so that he can have
if salam he does not he did not use and
because whether you take a positive will
rule the lady Ruth was worthy debate
there right so but in this case are is
right or the reflectance R is the R
square so giving you order magnitude so
that you can see it's very similar the
way of expressing over similar
reflectance transmittance right but
let's say class right class n is about
1.5 right how much reflection each
interface of glass has is the air is 1
so 1 point 5 minus 1 point 5 divided by
2 point 5 that's one face square 125 125
see is what 4% right so a typical one
glass interface give you 4 percent and
glass sides to interface so that's 0.9
six times four 96 so glass transmittance
is about 90 to 93 percent right it looks
like fine unless you do you really care
about efficiency 92 percent if you put a
server glass there layer there in solar
cells and any gaps and you'll get a see
below the lighting person who gives the
last 10 percent of your energy that's a
lot alright sometimes it's it looks
small secondly if you look at their
silicon right so what's good to remember
this lumbers 3 current any it was three
point five right
so three point five minus one so Sigma
interface how much reflection is two
point five divided by four point five
square right two point five divided by
four point five that's about fifty
percent fifty percent square twenty five
percent right so the glass interface
reflection is about the twenty five
thirty percent you feel helix silicon if
the all the light is absorbed
of course they even between the gap you
don't get absorbed then the immittance
of silicon then it's about 0.7 because
of refraction is the thirty percent and
the rest together absorbed absorption
equals the reflection the absorption
equals emission that's Kirchhoff's law
so so this gives you now the value that
you are saying and you can appreciate
okay we'll continue next lecture